une région qui regorge d'oxygène grâce à
sa forêt mais des hôpitaux qui en
manquent cruellement dans le nord du
pays en amazonas la situation se dégrade
au fil des jours les graves problèmes
d'approvisionnement en oxygène cause des
décès anticipé la mort de ma mère était
dû à l'oxygène et il y avait un silence
là dedans et j'étais ici à la merci de
la situation et je n'ai pas vraiment vu
ce qui s'est réellement passé là dedans
ma soeur était donc pressé et on lui a
demandé de venir immédiatement
c'est alors qu'elle a su que ma mère
était décédée à 4 heures du matin quel
en a été la cause le manque d'oxygène
dans l'hôpital moyen terme en vendant
moyens lévy
je suis ici depuis 9 heures du matin et
j'ai vu le désespoir de beaucoup de gens
moi y compris
je ne sais même pas comment expliquer ce
qui se passe avec notre pays le
gouverneur d'amazonas la firme l'état
est au moment le plus critique de la
pandémie
conséquence l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu de 19 heures à 6 heures du
matin a été annoncé jeudi pour une durée
de dix jours
l'objectif de cette mesure faire baisser
le taux de mortalité bien plus élevé que
la moyenne du pays
eduardo pas de vélo ministre brésilien
de la santé pointe du doigt un
effondrement des soins à manaus la
capitale de l'état
près de 400 bonbonne d'oxygène ont été
livrés ces cinq derniers jours mais
cette contribution s'avère insuffisante
pour pallier les carences actuelles
touché de plein fouet par la deuxième
vague de la pandémie le brésil s'apprête
à lancer sa campagne de vaccination de
20 janvier
si toutefois les demandes d'autorisation
d'urgence sont acceptées avant cette
date
une situation à laquelle vient s'ajouter
un élément qui inquiète les autorités
sanitaires la découverte au japon
d'invariants brésilien du coronavirus